[Music]
[Applause]
well let me bring in Dan Wilkin USA
Today National columnist talking about
college football how would you sum up
your column Dan
the way I would sum it up is that right
now there are so many different dynamics
that are going into how you know these
conference Commissioners or the big
conferences are looking at the NCAA how
they're looking at reform and the way to
address a lot of these issues like name
image and likeness and all the lawsuits
and Supreme Court cases and you know it
certainly seems like the next iteration
of this is going to be the big
conferences driven by the SEC in the Big
Ten because they make the most money
kind of having a subdivision all on
their own within division one to be able
to at least in their mind deal with all
of these things without the red tape and
without the smaller schools kind of
slowing down the the gears of of NCAA
rulemaking whether or not that's the
ultimate answer to any of their problems
is
I I have no idea you know I I think
there's just so many differences even
between the big schools on some of these
issues it's not an easy fix but it
certainly seems like whatever they do is
going to further squeeze out the little
guy and it feels like it's inevitable
not if but when and then you start to
look at this could you foresee maybe the
Big 12 grabs Arizona Arizona State and
Utah and Colorado tries to piece
something together there Big Ten Big Ten
might reach out to North Carolina and
North Carolina State and Syracuse if
they get Notre Dame the SEC might have
Florida State and Clemson and Miami
feels like we got three kind of
superpowers here and is that college
football
yeah I really think the best thing would
be if everybody could kind of just like
get in a room together and just put all
their cards on the table and hash it out
so we have something that that makes
sense as opposed to what we're going to
end up having over the next decade which
is sort of this slow migration of you
know a school here a school there into
these leagues and yeah they're going to
start to look crazy you know USC UCLA
the only West Coast Schools in the Big
Ten so you're telling me that they're
going to send their their volleyball
team and their tennis team you know all
across the country several times a year
that's not going to be good for anybody
except for the people who are counting
the money in those athletic departments
but
it just seems to me like you know right
now you just heard Jim Phillips at ACC
media days in in Charlotte you know he
kind of is is counting on this grant of
rights that binds these ACC schools
together until 2036. it would cost you
know probably nine figures for one of
these schools to go challenge that or to
try to get out of it to go to the Big
Ten so I think things are probably going
to be a little bit slower but everyone
sort of believes that we're heading to
this place where yeah if it's two
conferences if it's three conferences 50
Schools they're going to be the only
ones that matter in football you know
and maybe in other sports too I think we
haven't quite dealt with that reality
yet either
then you have Notre Dame Notre Dame
reportedly is looking at 75 million
dollar deal I believe with NBC
um if not because the Big Ten media
rights haven't been settled yet so it
feels like the Big Ten is sort of
waiting for Notre Dame if that doesn't
happen then if Notre Dame joins the pig
ten uh does that sound like the The
Logical Trail here I I think so
I don't think Notre Dame's priority is a
hundred percent about money now they're
going to obviously need to be
competitive in the marketplace they
prefer to be independent and I think
they will exhaust those options before
they jump in with any League including
the Big Ten and I think the main
consideration for Notre Dame is going to
be what is their access to the future of
the college football playoff because
they want to be in a situation where
they have a chance to win the whole
thing and you know I think the way it's
going to work out for Notre Dame to
their benefit is that the SEC would
prefer Notre Dame not join the Big Ten I
think the SEC would prefer Notre Dame
kind of keeping status quo because yeah
if the Big Ten doesn't expand anymore
this time or right now then there's
really not going to be a lot of
incentive for the SEC to do anything
either so that's why I kind of think
we're maybe in a little bit of a pause
here but yeah if Notre Dame woke up
tomorrow and said all right we're going
to go to the Big Ten and make you know
80 90 100 million dollars that is to me
the Tipping Point where you could see
things get really crazy really fast
what's the scc's goal
you know I I don't know that the SEC
necessarily has a goal that's tied to
number of teams I think they really just
want to be out front in terms of
determining what college athletics looks
like and to be able to
use whatever rules laws
paying players nil whatever the system
is they want to be in a position to
shape that to their competitive
advantage in in football uh they're
going to make all the money they want to
make you know any they could go issue
invitations tomorrow and schools will be
happy to go join the SEC but I don't
think that they're just going to take
schools to take them I think anyone they
take would have to be a value-add and I
don't think that right now there's very
many schools other than say Notre Dame
you know maybe Clemson maybe Florida
State North Carolina but it's it's a
small handful that right now would
enhance the SEC so I think they're just
kind of lying in weight right now seeing
how it shakes out with the Big Ten
I'm surprised that grown-ups are
surprised about name image and likeness
I I mean
how do they not see that this would be
oh I remember listening to a coach he's
a current coach don't want to say his
name but he said nobody's going to spend
money for an offensive lineman I said
why not he protects your Star
Quarterback he opens the holes for your
running backs nobody's going to spend
money for defensive lineman I go why not
look at the draft those are the guys who
go in the top ten I could this is crazy
that they're they're basically going
wait what just happened here where are
we going with name image and likeness
well I think that there could be some
settling of the market in the sense that
this is the first year where kids that
were uh signing these deals as recruits
are ending up on college campuses and
guess what a lot of them are not going
to be good players or they're at least
not going to be impactful players to the
level that the people who paid that
money would maybe expect so is that
going to chill the market a little bit
are people going to be you know maybe
less eager to you know write six figure
checks to 18 year olds who are totally
unproven as college football players
we'll we'll see what surprises me is
just that the leadership of college
sports and you you're hearing it at
media days you heard Sankey at the SEC
Phillips at the ACC they're talking
about still relying on Congress to come
in and write some National Standard that
that takes this Patchwork of state laws
and puts everybody on the same playing
field and you know I just kind of want
to you know shake these guys by the
Scruff of their neck and say congress is
not going to do anything they're not
going to save you they can barely get
things passed right now that actually do
good things for you know hundreds of
millions of people this is not a high
priority item for congress I don't care
if it's Democrats or Republicans in
charge it's hard to pass anything it's
hard to come to an agreement but they
actually want to do in Washington is
have these hearings so that they can
drag Mark emmered or conference
Commissioners you know in front of them
and and get their social media Clips by
lecturing them that's what they want
they're not interested in passing
anything this is going to be up to the
NCAA leadership and the members
themselves to solve this you don't need
any of these state laws you've already
made
you've already made it legal to accept
these payments write your own rules if
you are afraid of getting taken to court
so be it you get taken to court over
everything else just do it and then see
what happens and don't rely on Congress
to act because they're not going to do
it
Dan great to talk to you again thanks
for joining us
thanks Dan appreciate it Dan wonkin USA
Today National columnist